desde hace 40 años una gigantesca mina
de níquel a cielo abierto se consume
poco a poco el territorio ancestral de
los indígenas zenú en la región
colombiana de Córdoba en el norte de ese
país para nosotros Eso significa es
destrucción para eso nosotros significa
es un deforme de nuestra madre tierra
Porque ya quedan contaminadas las aguas
quedan contaminadas los árboles todo lo
que es el el campo Silvestre queda
contaminado las aves desaparecieron y
ahí y también las plantas medicinales
Israel Aguilar es el portavoz de las
comunidades indígenas en la región según
él la mina no sólo ha afectado la fauna
y la flora cada vez que sopla el viento
de allá para acá partículas y
minipartículas micropartículas llegan
hasta acá hasta la comunidad y eso se
está sintiendo Los indicadores de
nosotros era que siendo nosotros Tan
resistente porque había tanta enfermedad
y ya cuando nos tocó el cáncer
a la población cuando dijimos No ya esto
se está saliendo de control
proliferación de varios tipos de cáncer
problemas respiratorios reumatológicos y
dermatológicos en el pueblo de guacarí
todo el mundo está enfermo
[Música]
del 2000 hacia acá
eso la salud aquí se ha deteriorado
tanto que la gente sufre mucho
eso me cae un abdomen un ardor en la
vista inclusive en estos días tuve que
di a una farmacia conseguí gotas para la
vista porque me arde la vista y es
botando agua bastante
y traigo bastante tiempo esto así
yo mi cuerpo de aquí de mi rodillas para
arriba ácido así un general en eso
sufrir
hacen 16 años Yo estoy en esa lucha y de
10 años para acá me ha salido si yo una
verruga eso me complica mucho porque ya
en mi vista aquí y está aquí este lado
hace una década las comunidades en un se
movilizaron masivamente y bloquearon el
acceso a la mina obtuvieron ayudas y
algunas indemnizaciones Y eso
la empresa minera construyó y renovó
cerca de 1.250 viviendas
Yolanda fue una de las beneficiarias
hace dos años Cerro matoso Le entregó
una casa
Esto se está se partió esta casa que
todavía tiene dos años
Yolanda perdió su salud y a cambio
recibió una vivienda en mal estado las
paredes están destruidas y el techo de
chapa arde bajo el calor Tropical ellos
como digo yo jugaron con nosotros que
los engañaron pudieron no a esos indios
les vamos a dar la casa y ya fuera no es
nadie con eso se contentan porque tienen
su casa pero no Sabiendo lo sufría que
estamos sufriendo por lo que estamos
sufriendo
la mina de cerro matoso es propiedad de
la compañía australiana South 32 que
surgió de la escisión del gigante minero
vhp billitum
la empresa aceptó reunirse con nosotros
para una visita supervisada
desde 1982 hemos consolidado nuestra
operación como una de las más seguras de
Colombia la explotación se extiende
sobre 85.000 hectáreas el níquel se
extrae de un gran cráter y es
transformado allí mismo en
[Música]
en 2022 salieron más de 40.000 toneladas
de sus hornos no muy lejos el perímetro
minero la compañía creó su propia
clínica administrada por la fundación de
la empresa los habitantes de los
alrededores pueden recibir atención
médica gratuita los diagnósticos siempre
resultan favorables para ser reumatoso
Nosotros con las atenciones periódicas
sabemos realmente cómo se comportan las
condiciones de salud y definitivamente
no hay un perfil epidemiológico especial
y particular por estar viviendo
alrededor de ese reumatozoos en el pulso
jurídico con las poblaciones de los
alrededores poderosos abogados defienden
a la compañía y a menudo es ella quien
tiene la última palabra por su parte el
clan del Golfo el grupo armado que
controla la región ve con malos ojos
cualquier protesta en contra de las
grandes empresas Israel recibe
regularmente amenazas de muerte a pesar
de los riesgos sigue trabajando con las
comunidades
en Puerto Colombia a 750 metros de la
mina se ven las mismas miradas cansadas
que en los pueblos vecinos y existen las
mismas enfermedades Y problemas de
fertilidad los habitantes lograron
hacerse exámenes médicos que demuestran
la presencia de níquel en la orina y la
sangre nosotros los indígenas jamás
hemos estado en contra de los
desarrollos
de los desarrollos económicos no pero
nosotros que estamos en contra es en
Cómo
activan esos procesos Cómo realizas en
actividades que las quieren realizar es
pasándose por encima de la por encima de
los humanos que están alrededor sin
importarle un como decimos nosotros
acá como sin importarle nada es como si
llegaran aquí como si aquí no hubiera
gente y
Nosotros también somos gente en 2022 el
permiso de explotación de ser reumatoso
se prorrogó hasta 2044
la mina gigante que amenaza el futuro de
los indígenas en un no está cerca de
desaparecer